konntest du
ich wollte dir nicht wehtun glaubten
aber ich konnte was ich konnte nicht
wissen dass du in georgia freunde zeit
ach ja und mit einer x-beliebigen
hättest du fröhlich weiter gemacht
und wenn ich jetzt nicht hier wäre
wahrscheinlich auch so lange bis seine
kleine dumme freundin endlich dahinter
gekommen wäre
weißt du wie ich mich fühle
anstatt mir beim ein problem mit meiner
mutter zu helfen mit drückt meine mutter
jetzt hast du mal deine mutter aus dem
spiel
du bist ausgezogen und von ihr
loszukommen dreht es doch andauernd nur
von mir das ist doch nicht wahr
weißt du was nicht war es dass deine
mutter diese ganzen krankheiten hat
seitdem du ausgezogen das hat sie eine
krankheit nach der anderen
jetzt verdacht auf asthma dann dann hat
sie räume dann staub allergien diabetes
so stimmt der einsatz noch krebs
du bist du von mir schlafen
dicke luft heute in der wg was ich habe
keine lust mit ihr darüber zu regeln und
außerdem geht es sich auch nichts an
naja wenn der haussegen schief hängt
geht es nicht wohl etwas an aber ist was
ich denke und was ich mache
zur ehrung so ich wollte doch nur helfen
und mag
er geht ich auch nichts an
lothar hieß es tut mir leid
okay wir reden aneinander vorbei
aber ich wollte nie dass das passiert
wirklich nicht
ich hab mich verfügt